definitely don't spank its behind today
it's an here and here at ABC science we
ask you to suggest the next animal for
the how deadly video series and we heard
you loud and clear let's do one bad
excuse me
really don't you dare
let's do this
wombats oh he's so angry oh you ladies
got a lot to be angry about
that's one that is frickin hilarious
when their little baby wombat 'let's
there's super cute and they fully around
like a puppy and they're really adorable
but then they hit puberty and they begin
to question life itself and they get
angry it's got quite a mouth on it the
bloke I mean not the one that it's not
your boss it's really rare for them to
do this like this has to be a pretty
aggravated little individual normally
when a wombat feels threatened it will
run away and go into its burrow when one
bites attack oh Jesus Christ but they
can be aggressive and they do have
strong little legs and they are heavy
and their primary weapon is the charge
are you bastard it's pretty amazing and
these guys getting it in full they just
run at you and there's a little bit of
biting around the ankles that can happen
I didn't realize one bats had such a big
teeth eh oh he's got a scratch yeah one
bat teeth pretty cool which is a phrase
I know you never thought that you would
look at on social media they actually
keep on growing the whole entire life of
the wombat and that's big
they use it to grind so much vegetation
they just keep on growing and wearing
them down over their whole life the best
thing to do would probably be to beat a
retreat and let the wombat you know calm
down wow I think this is technically
referred to as the zuni's now one that's
actually pretty quick apparently one's
being clocked over a hundred and fifty
meters at 40k an hour that's really
quick I don't think I'd be able to keep
that up and I think that Usain Bolt when
he did a hundred meters he was like what
going 38 K is an hour or something like
that so the one that's faster of course
if you really wanted to beat them all
you have to do is run a little bit more
than 150 meters because they're really
bad at distance running
[Music]
excuse me excuse me the one that's like
now line up mate this is a good
scratching spot
I think it's pretending that human isn't
there I have it on good authority from
wildlife carers that the way to or one
that's hard is through their bum because
they really love scratching it excuse me
excuse me hazel I need to get the clean
washing in there - one that see how
solid they are any time I think that
this wombat is trying to get into a
burrow it doesn't know it's getting into
a washing machine it's essentially
trying to hide they're nocturnal
they'll generally only be out at night
so it looks like it's daytime and it's
trying to get in a burrow it's just the
Burrow is on spin cycle ah now a wombats
bum is sort of like its temple and its
protection because underneath the skin
they've actually got four bony plates
that are sort of melded together to
create almost like a shield and then on
top of that there's sort of a fatty
layer there's skin really thick skin and
that really beautiful thick fur and
essentially it's really hard for any
animal to pierce that skin or get
through to the wombat yes it just puts
the bum into the hole completely blocks
it no one can get in no one can get out
the warm bodies can oh there's a Joey
hasn't developed the massive bootie yet
well thanks
gee that really has the that Bush in
some senses right wombats are lucky when
it comes to a natural disaster like
bushfire because they have an amazing
temperature defense system which is
their burrow system these systems can be
epic like they've traced some and
they're 90 meters long and have 20
entrances so there's been studies that
look at what uses one that burrows and
they are things like lizards other
mammals there's even Wallabies that have
gone in there on occasion once you
survive a bushfire this is what you've
got to live in there's not much green
for those wombats to eat so it's a
pretty heartbreaking thing to see even
though they're beautiful wombats
are amazing but they're not deadly
you're more likely to fall over in one
of their holes so that you are to
actually be attacked by a wombat that
being said it has happened and if a
wombat is looking aggressive starting to
charge you the way to avoid it would be
to exit the area or get up high stand up
on top of a picnic table or a chair so
that the wombat you know basically can
go about its business
I hoped you liked that one and if you
did hit subscribe for more videos and if
you've got a suggestion for an animal
that you'd like me to look out for how
deadly why don't you leave your
suggestions in the comments below and
I'll make sure I read them I'll catch
you next time